well hello believed nation in this video
I'll be summarizing one of the greatest
self-help books of all time
pink and crow rage this book is one of
Evans top 5 book recommendations so make
sure to watch closely and take notes my
name is Manny wah and I'm the founder of
2000 books calm and the two thousand
books youtube channel where we
summarized some of the world's greatest
business and personal development books
I have personally read over a thousand
business and self-help books and in this
video I'm summarizing a book that is not
only one of Evans top 5 books but it is
also one of my top 5 books so here we go
thinking courage is arguably one of the
greatest self-help books of all time why
because in it is the combined knowledge
about how to become successful from some
of the greatest minds of the 20th
century including john d rockefeller who
was the richest man the world has ever
seen
andrew carnegie the biggest steel tycoon
of his times and second only to
rockefeller in terms of wealth henry
ford the founder of Ford Motor Company
Thomas Edison the inventor of lightbulb
and holder of over 2,000 patterns and
over 500 such great minds the author
Napoleon Hill spent nearly 30 years
interviewing these great men to figure
out what made them successful and the
book is a distillation of those ideas
and in this video I will compress the
entire book in the knowledge from these
500 great men into one encompassing idea
that will simplify the whole book for
you and even though the title of the
book is thinking Grow Rich the idea is
applied to accomplishing any goal that
you desire now here's the
all-encompassing idea in order to do
great things
whether it be to accumulate great riches
or any other goal for that matter we
have to enroll and harness the power of
our subconscious mind and that is what
we will discuss in this video going
forward now why do we need to do that
well we all have two minds inside of us
the conscious and the subconscious
however in terms of sheer power the
subconscious mind is orders of magnitude
more powerful than the conscious mind
there is literally no comparison if the
size of the conscious mind is the size
of a microwave oven
the subconscious mind is the size of the
Milky Way it's extremely powerful and
the computational resources it
as are humongous millions of times more
powerful than the conscious mind so in
order to accomplish your big goals you
need to harness the power of your
subconscious mind by programming it with
the goal that you want and how do we
harness the power of the subconscious
mind and program it for what we want
well given the nature of our
subconscious mind and the conscious mind
it is not easy to program the
subconscious mind but it is entirely
possible and this book is all about
understanding precisely how to do that
so let's understand the basics of the
subconscious mind and then we will talk
about the keys to program it for massive
success firstly even though the
subconscious mind is way more powerful
than the conscious mind it is still
being controlled by the conscious mind
our conscious mind is the master of our
subconscious mind the subconscious mind
is like a garden while the conscious
mind is the gardener the conscious mind
is sowing the seeds of part while the
subconscious is working to bring those
thoughts to fruition
second of all we have to understand that
our subconscious mind is always working
and for most people it is working
against them
now you might be wondering why the
subconscious mind would work against you
well it is because of the thoughts and
emotions that are dominating your
existence every single moment every
single day if your thoughts are
dominated by negativity fear poverty
failure well the subconscious mind is
busy making those thoughts a reality for
you and hence it is working against you
on the other hand if you are feeding
your subconscious mind deliberately
design thoughts and feelings of riches
success positivity
well the subconscious mind gets busy
making those thoughts a reality for you
now the challenge is that if you do not
actively plant deliberately chosen
thoughts and emotions in there it will
work on the thoughts it receives as a
result of neglect and unfortunately
those are not usually positive uplifting
thoughts you are constantly being
bombarded with negativity all around you
thirdly the subconscious mind is
objective it does not distinguish
between positive or negative it does not
distinguish between a penny or a million
dollars it will take whatever thoughts
and emotions you think and feel and get
busy making them a reality
whether positive or negative okay so now
that we understand the subconscious mind
a little better how do we get about
programming our subconscious mind for
great success how do we create that
burning desire that literally turns on
the power of the subconscious mind in
our favor and makes us unstoppable well
here are the five keys to do exactly
that first of all we must have a
definite purpose we must become very
clear on what we want on the specific
goal we want the clear the purpose or
the end goal the easier it is to get
there only when we are clear about our
goal can we program that goal into our
subconscious mind if you provide your
subconscious mind with no clear purpose
or goals you will get no real power from
it it will be like a giant ship with
immense power but without any
destination to aim for so what's the use
of a ship without a clear destination a
lot of people have these wake calls
about maybe becoming rich or losing
weight but those goals are so big that
it's almost useless you have to be very
clear you have to have a very clear goal
a very clear dollar amount that will
help you harness the power of your
subconscious mind because it allows you
to focus your effort and it gives you a
clarity of direction clarity of making
decisions the second key to programming
your subconscious mind is to use the
power of artists suggestion now order
suggestions are deliberately designed
statements or commands you give to
yourself also known as affirmations once
you know what you want you must repeat
that command to your subconscious mind
over and over and over and over and over
again no end to it there's no end to
maintaining your garden and you have to
keep on doing this you never stop doing
it so you keep on repeating these
affirmations to yourself these are the
suggestions to yourself over and over
again the third key to program your
subconscious mind is to use the power of
emotions to direct your subconscious
mind now it is not enough to think about
your calls and just repeat them you must
mix those thoughts of your calls with
emotions the emotions you want to feel
when the goal will be accomplished the
subconscious mind only understands the
language of emotions emotionless
thoughts do not affect the subconscious
mind that is a fact it does not
understand the sub
just does not understand the language of
logic or reason so any language you use
in order to program your subconscious
mind has to involve emotions you have to
feel the feelings in order to be able to
program your subconscious mind you must
mix your thoughts with positive emotions
or thoughts mixed with negative emotions
will unfortunately reach your
subconscious mind by default and
thoughts mixed with emotions have a
magnetic force to them in the sense that
they attract similar thoughts and
emotions positive emotions will keep on
attracting more of those positive
thoughts more of those positive emotions
so your job is to minimize the inflow of
negative and disempowering thoughts and
emotions and to instead program your
subconscious with deliberately designed
positive and empowering thoughts
emotions and feelings and when we can
consistently do that that's when we have
the key to unlocking our subconscious
mind okay the fourth key to programming
your subconscious mind is visualization
and acting as if in order to program our
subconscious mind we must see and feel
the goal as if the goal is already
accomplished that you already have what
you desire ask yourself how would you
act if you had already accomplished your
goal
how would you feel what would you do
what feelings would dominate your mind
the key to visualization is to actually
be able to see and feel yourself as
having already accomplished the call
rather than thinking of it as a distant
possibility so if you have a goal of
making a million dollars by December
31st of next year visualize yourself on
December 31st as having already
accomplished that call don't think of it
as something you would like to
accomplish in the future that is
creating the feeling of not having the
goal right now instead feel that it is
December 31st of next year right now and
you have already accomplished the call I
really cannot emphasize this point
enough so you might want to just rewind
and watch this point a few times because
it's loaded with great wisdom right here
okay the fifth key to programming your
subconscious mind is persistence and
repetition so what is the price of being
able to harness the power of your
subconscious mind it is as Napoleon Hill
says it it is everlasting persistence
and thoughts mix with emotions mix with
faith
endless repetition of that desire mixed
with positive emotions and mixed with
faith no matter what the circumstances
no matter what you see externally in the
world
there's no lower price we can pave we
must consistently persist and repeat
these thoughts over and over and over
again we must decide to programmer
subconscious mind and there is no end to
it we have to do it over and over and
over again so the amazing thing is that
as you begin to increase your thoughts
about that goal and you mix it with your
positive emotions and what will happen
is those thoughts and those emotions
will begin to attract more of such
thoughts and emotions until you become
completely charged with this thought
pattern with these emotions ok so we
just talked about the five keys to
programming your subconscious mind
however there is one power strategy that
literally puts this whole book on
steroids this strategy makes the above
five steps automatic and that strategy
is to burn the boats now let me tell you
the story of Spanish Conqueror Hernan
Cortes back in the 1500s to really
explain what it means to burn the boats
when Hernan Cortes warships arrived on
what was then the Aztec empire he had
clear intentions of fighting the Aztecs
and conquering that area of what is now
modern-day Mexico however he quickly
realized that his army was badly
outnumbered almost of the ratio of one
to 100 and he saw that his soldiers were
starting to hesitate and thinking of
retreating in case the war did not go
according to plan so in order to get the
very best out of his soldiers in order
to get them to win he ordered his men to
burn their pots and once the ports were
born there was no way of retrieving the
soldiers knew very clearly that they
only had two options either win or die
there was no other way out do or die and
that created a burning obsession inside
of them to win and to live and that is
why his army went on to win the war even
though they were outnumbered one to
hundred now that is the power of burning
the boats it quickly gets us to harness
the power of our subconscious mind
because when our survival is at stake
the subconscious mind brings all its
power to
on a given situation in those situations
we become unstoppable so if you want to
create a burning obsessive pulsating
desire for something if you really want
to program your subconscious mind with
your goal you need to cut off all other
paths of retreat you need to cut off all
other possibilities you have to go all
in just one option and sometimes these
situations are externally manufactured
for us for example you are running out
of money in your venture and you have a
clear deadline by which you must make
the business work or the business will
die many great entrepreneurs have
actually created at those moments as the
ones that really turn their businesses
around at other times we have to burn
the boats ourselves when there are no
external manufactured situations
available to us and one of the ways you
can do that is to publicly commit to a
goal or another way to do that is to
create real deadlines with real
consequences if the goal is not
accomplished whatever you do to burn the
boats make sure that it leads to a state
of burning obsession where you are
almost obsessively thinking about the
goal you need that fire you need that
obsession you need that in order to
program your subconscious mind and that
is what will trigger you to greatness so
there you have it an in-depth
understanding of thinking courage so
just to recap what we learned was that
in order to accomplish our greatest
goals we must enroll and harness the
power of our subconscious minds just
trying to use the conscious mind to
accomplish our goals is not enough and
we talked about the five keys to harness
the power of the subconscious mind and
then we also talked about the one power
strategy that literally makes us
unstoppable so if you enjoyed this Think
and Grow Rich summary and learn
something new from it I'm sure you will
love the 2000 books youtube channel as
well the link to the 2000 books youtube
channel is in the description below so
come check it out on the 2000 books
channel we have summarized some of the
greatest books in the field of
entrepreneurship sales marketing
management leadership strategy self our
productivity happiness motivation self
confidence self esteem success mindset
positive psychology emotional
intelligence social skills people skills
billionaire biographies basically all
the books that will help you succeed in
business and in life so come check it
out the link is in the description below
if you like this video check out the
Rich Dad Poor Dad animated book review
summary also by two thousand bucks the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there let's try to
understand why the rich are rich in the
poor poor and the middle class
well middle class has explained by
Robert Kiyosaki in his book